σας υποδέχθηκα θετικάδεν περίμεναν ότι θα μπορούσανανταποκριθώς τις προσδοκίες τους ηκί ξεστιγμή που μάρια είε
τ καννόδάνομεφίοπως έγινε η πρόταση δνα υποργόπτη πήρε εντηλέφωνο ου το ίπο δεν τεμαρτος μετά
πολι τη σύσκεψη περανν υπολιτική αρχηκής τογραυό το προερτότου μεία η παναγιόπου δεν την διαφέρια
οι πρετρία τηςτσδε πούμε το μερό μερκαι φέρο δυστυχώς ελάχιστι έχουν καταλάβει το πού βρισκόμαστε
νομίζονται αυτό εν είμαι θέμα να αντίληψεης και πρέπει να σταματής όσονεκινή είμαστε για να
μη πούμε κόνς που βλέποετα ποροεατο ότι θα έχουμε πυρκαγές αυτό είναι ένα δεδομένο στόχος
είναι απεξάρτηση από τις καιρικές υτικες ιότ ι κύπροςδεν θα μπορεί το πρόβλημα που έχουμε
με το χαλούμε είναι ποχικότητα α θέση του υπουργού από την ημέρα που την αναλαμβάνεις
γνωρίσεις ότι είναι φημέν δουλεύκο για να αφίσω κάτι πίσουμε ηλες κα άλλο να αντε
αλλά υπόρκα σήμερα μαζί σας και εδώ στο πλάτο η υπουργός γεωργία σε κύρια μαρία
παναγιότου και πανγιώ σας χαίρετο υχαριστώπιστο μαζί γυφαστήπροκλση ενικός υπληθυνδικός για να σκολεδικός πάννα ρωτήσω
αρχι κάποια ίναι η μαρα παναγιότου χαδή ευκαιρια να βαντήσω την ίδια ανερώτηση βριο βολίες
μου έίνε σαν συνάδελφο σας και θαθα δώσω την ίδι να πάντηση ίναι αυτό το
οποίο πρεσβέβει και είναι η μαρία παναγιότου πρώτα είνι μάμα το έχιλάειο άνο και δως
έχει λέσι νο ίπέμου να σταματήσουν ανα το λέο του οι μαιαπαναγιο του είναι είναι
ένος άνθρωπους που αγαπά τον τόπο ου και αγαβά για τους ανθρώπους του τοπου του
ε τούτο είναι κάτι με το οποίο ξεκοινό ότι μέρα μου ε διάμου δύναμη να
συνεχίσουμε εξυπνησς